Hi, my name is Lily Bond.
I'm the director of marketing here at 3Play Media.
And on a daily basis, I work with all types of marketing content.
So, I do blogs, I do white papers.
I do webinars all the time, go to a lot of conferences,...
...and then I manage our team and all of our marketing operations.
So, we produce closed captions and transcripts,...
...which is an accommodation for the deaf and hard-of-hearing community.
And my favorite part of my job is that I get to help people.
My days are never the same.
So, one thing that's great about 3Play, for me at least,...
...is the diversity of things that I'm working on.
I never like doing the same thing over and over again.
So, on one day, I might be writing a new blog post.
On another day, I might be producing a webinar.
On another day, I might be travelling across the country to a conference.
And then I get to meet with people from all different teams in the company...
...and work on new product releases.
And I find it really exciting.